et nous sommes avec ian taele larrère
spécialistes du numérique et cofondateur
du site
ok doc point fr bonsoir merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation alors facebook
rejoint le mouvement de contestation
contre apple et sa taxe vous comprenez
cette position à ce que facebook cherche
à a gagné en capital sympathie selon
vous alors c'est évident facebook
cherche à s'attirer le capital sympathie
en tapant sur apple qui est la cible un
peu privilégié du moment on pourrait
faire le même reproche à google qui a
via sa plateforme le plextor les mêmes
conditions
alors on parle de taxe mme stein taxes
en fait on appelle ça des frais de
service et donc à chaque fois qu'un euro
est dépensée sur une de ces plateformes
en fait les plateformes l'apple store ou
le playsport pour google prélève 30% qui
correspondent à la mise en service pas
de l'écosystème soit d'apple soin de soi
de de google il
et justifie ses coûts notamment avec la
sécurité et puis également ses
écosystèmes il les et ils les ont
construit au fur et à mesure des années
et finalement bas aujourd'hui il récolte
les frais enfin les frais les
investissements qu'ils ont consentis
tout au long de ces années
est-ce que vous pouvez nous expliquer en
quoi consiste la démarche de facebook
vis-à-vis des pme présentes sur le
réseau social
qu'est ce qu'il reproche à apple
précisément alors aujourd'hui facebook a
décidé de lancer une grande opération
auprès des entreprises des entrepreneurs
qui est de pouvoir vendre ses services
sans commission quand on passe via
facebook
mais évidemment comme la plupart des
gens aujourd'hui utilisent leur
smartphone pour se connecter à facebook
du coup facebook est dépendant des
commissions qui sont versés par
question réclamées par ces plateformes
apple en tête et donc ils veulent
quelque part supprimé ces frais de
transaction qui passe obligatoirement
aujourd'hui pour tous les développeurs
et facebook fait pas exception à la
règle
et peu importe finalement que facebook
ne soit qu'un intermédiaire et ne
prélève pas de frais au passage c'est la
même chose pour tous je vais faire une
petite analogie tout le monde connaisse
tifa ils ont exactement les mêmes
problématiques
cette fois ci les tpe les entrepreneurs
bas ce sont les gens qui produisent de
la musique
ils ont leur musique sur spotify et
spotify vend également de la musique
pendant des abonnements illimités et bac
quand vous achetez un abonnement 10
euros sur sur internet via votre
smartphone en fait vous réglisse 3 euros
apple 7 euros pour ce motif haye qui
reverse ensuite une partie de l'argent
aux personnes ou aux éditeurs de musique
de son catalogue appel et est dans son
droit en quoi ce serait scandaleux bas
de poursuivre cette politique et cette
commission 30% pour tout achat alors ce
qui est discuté c'est le montant il faut
savoir qu'aujourd'hui quand on fait des
transactions financières notamment diabo
nos cartes de paiement on est autour de
3 % de commission et la 30%
la question c'est est-ce que c'est pas
démesuré alors les les plateformes les
gaffes à apple et google se défendent en
disant que ce ne sont pas que des
transactions financières c'est aussi
l'écosystème qu'elles ont construit les
milliards de personnes qui se connectent
à leur plate forme et qu'il met à
disposition si vous voulez c'est un peu
des supermarchés géant pour les
applications
aujourd'hui il ya plus de 1,5 million
d'applications sur l'apple store et donc
voilà on est on est un peu face à un
grand magasin a dit pas si vous voulez
vendre dans mon magasin
il faut accepter mes conditions et de
l'autre côté bar
les éditeurs de logiciels sont pas
forcément en mesure de négocier c'est 30
% ou sait rien et c'est sans doute là où
il ya matière à discussion alors ils
sont elles sont nombreuses les
entreprises avoir rejoint ce mouvement
de contestation
et qu'est ce qui pourrait faire plier
apple de mettre un terme à cette
commission 30% alors aujourd'hui ce qui
pourrait faire piller apple c'est
peut-être les etats-unis ou l'europe
il ya la commission européenne qui a été
saisie à quelques temps d'un cas
similaire d'une d'un éditeur qui disait
mais c'est pas possible
vous êtes en situation qu'avec de quasi
monopole et finalement c'est une entrave
à la concurrence
on verra où pas si la commission
européenne est sensible aux arguments on
est au tout début de la procédure ça
peut prendre des années mais les sols
sont vraiment gigantesque en jeu de
l'autre côté les plates formes elles
n'ont pas du tout décidé de l'abandonner
les armes
il ya quelques temps apple et google ont
choisi de retirer le jeu forte mythe de
l'heure de leur store puisque fortuny tu
essayais si vous voulez de contourner
les règles et donc avec un système de
paiement parallèle pour échapper à cette
à cette commission à ses frais de
service de 30% et les éditeurs fin du
coup la dame à représailles des
plateformes c'est du coup vous n'avez
plus le droit d'être sur nous sur nos
store si vous acceptez pas nos règles
ça sera le mois de la fin y admet
l'arrêt remercie pour cet éclairage je
rappelle que vous êtes spécialiste du
numérique et co fondateur du site au
québec point fr